where did you get the jacket from so I
made this jacket oh my gosh like you
collected all the patches yeah well kind
of I bought a vintage lot of patches on
eBay and then some of them were my dad
like my dad volunteered at this um fire
station in college I am in love with
your jacket I think it's so cool how you
like made it yourself yeah I like
your personality and you're also very
pretty oh thank you
that's so cool thank you guys oh my gosh
my name's Lizzy I like to read books I'm
sorry reading books are just kind of
boring you don't like doing anything
else skiing like winter skiing and water
skiing okay so then like why read books
yeah so so Friday night so you're like
you know what let me get on the Dance
Floor what are you gonna start doing
just like a little bit of those
that hurt my knees
sorry I dropped it
I I probably can't ever handle something
like that again